I eat T-bone steaks I live barbell place
I'm getting sweeter than a dribble
chocolate cake that man of the hour pro
wrestling is unique because
who are successful have Charisma and I
had I had a natural Charisma I was a
natural for pro wrestling WWE legend
Superstar Billy Graham has died he was
79 years old
I am the Superstar TMZ reports that the
wrestling icon died on Wednesday his
family previously revealed on a GoFundMe
page Graham was facing multiple health
issues
and had been in the hospital for weeks
introducing from Paradise Valley Arizona
Superstar
Billy Graham Graham was best known as a
Pioneer in professional wrestling
there's more colors on my body than the
rainbow in the sky Daddy when I started
wrestling in 1970 in Calgary Alberta
came back to the United States took off
people promoters started calling me I
was the first one to come on the scene
in pro wrestling with a real physique I
was combining bodybuilding and pro
wrestling together which was almost
unheard of because of the obvious uh
strain you have to wrestle you have to
body build and you're dealing with
injuries you're dealing with dieting and
but I did it and I was really the first
one to do those two sports
simultaneously after after inspiring a
generation of wrestlers Graham was
inducted into the WWE Hall of Fame in
2004. Superstar Billy Graham was just a
new dimension redefining evolving the
term of sports entertainment I dabble a
little bit in pro football had people
who were also playing pro ball who were
wrestling in the off season and they
just said here it is I'm going to take a
look at it I took a look at it I said
this is Taylor Made For Me